[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends
talk oh there you go see
we built it up so much about life for a
long time
i technically didn't mess it up i just
paused in the middle
yeah you kind of had it i just stopped
and i picked it up
i'm right and i'm linked this week
at the round table of not as dim
lighting in our secondary but special
location
we're going to talk about the questions
that keep you up at night that was the
prompt that we put
out there into the world you know we put
these prompts out into the world
on our twitter feed follow us on twitter
at mythical.com
if you want to see what these things are
if you want to be a part of it if you
want
to hear us say your twitter handle
and then rip your contribution to shreds
or not that's not going to happen it
never happened super appreciative i'm
going to
lodge you with praise so we go we go
through these things thoughts
you know we'll come up with these
prompts
or uh kiko or jacob will help us come up
with these prompts sometimes things that
might lead to discussion we have no clue
what people are going to say
and then we're you know we i do link we
sift through it
i've been a student of the internet for
so many years i know exactly what kind
of responses we're going to get
well did you know that the responses to
what question keeps you up at night
could be pretty heavy yeah i mean we
live in heavy times
yeah and then once we were going through
them
i think we just had a different we had a
different vibe so we did a wrapper
we didn't pick the um who's the wrapper
the heaviest ones this conversation
we're going to keep it light what was
the wrapper that had heavy
it was uh heavy d heavy d heavy d in the
boys
heavy d heavy there was a z heavy times
would be like the perfect comeback album
for heavy d right now he is dead that'd
be quite a comeback
[Laughter]
if someone has died and then they make a
new album
quite a comeback is a good one of course
there's a lot of people
putting out post humus albums yeah
people think tupac's still alive
i know well i mean what do you think of
the new pop smoke
i i've heard i've heard my son talking
about this
i can't say i've partaken i i only know
one pop smoke song i mean if someone's
dead
i don't really want to get into him
lincoln was a huge fan of juice world
before he died
and then it's just it's so sad now you
know i thought you said you didn't want
to be heavy
you did it i was talking about coming
back and he said he was dead you could
have lied to me
you could have said yeah yeah yeah he's
back what was that heavy d
song what was the song he had like a
song or two you know it
wasn't great she heard of his voice was
kind of like his voice was
he kind of had a newscaster voice it was
interesting huh the way that he rapped
he had
he had a newscaster kind of never
thought of it like that kind of lilt
to his voice um i have something i need
to catch you up on
you and you um do it
so some of you who may uh follow me
closely
on on the twitter or even follow my wife
closely on the twitter
know that we tend to get into these
little back and forths and sometimes
she'll take a picture of me doing
something stupid or whatever
and a couple weeks ago and maybe a few
weeks ago by this point
she took a picture of me with a feline
which is a is the technical term for a
cat
now you might know that i typically i'm
not fond of cats i was once
hypnotized to try to like cats
and i couldn't i tried i gave it the old
college try
and i
have stated clearly that i don't hate
cats that just strongly prefer dogs
right
lots of theories about why this is i
think you've even said
that so the times when you assert your
hate for cats
it's kind of a bit it's a it's a comedic
assertion
yeah it's fun it's based it's one of
those things that's based in the truth
that i prefer dogs it's height
it's hot it's a heightened debris i
wouldn't you know i would not own a cat
uh or have a cat as a pet if you don't
like the term own for pets
um and some people have been like well
you know people who don't like cats
are full of themselves uh they want
somebody to worship them
they're afraid of rejection maybe all
that's true i don't know but i do like i
do prefer dogs more
however my wife and i've been taking a
lot of walks
during the covet and
i don't know six weeks ago we're walking
past this house that we
have walked past many times and a
what do you call the cat that's like an
orange striped cat garfield
uh i thought that was a tabby
cat i don't know i'm not a cat expert i
don't i don't know much let's just call
it a garfield like cat
makes a beeline for us as we're passing
this house
okay like coming at us hard
and at first i was a little bit like and
when a cat's coming at you hard i mean
somebody like me is who's not typically
scared of animals it's like what's this
guy going to do
um what is it called orange cat breed
it's
what you have is what i've seen what
breeder orange cats
tabby orange tabby you're right persian
munchkin
american bobtail british short hair
bengal maine [ __ ]
obsidian and it was like it was like
that it was like your classic
short-haired that one right there that's
it yeah it was like
the cat i had as a child thomas who only
came to my house
thomas and visited me in the shed out
back whenever he felt like it
so anyway this tabby cat approaches us
and begins to meow loudly and again not
being a cat expert i don't know exactly
what this means but he does not seem to
be aggressive at all
and then he proceeds to have both of you
or just you both of us
then he proceeds to do that thing where
cats rub up against your leg
okay extensively to say hey i like you i
love you and this doesn't happen often
with cats and me
or cats and people that i knew of
and uh but i'm immediately sort of into
this cat i mean i gotta be honest
oh yeah right there on the street and
again this probably
you know fits perfectly the theory that
people who want to be worshipped and
loved
and are afraid of rejection like dogs
more and if you can find a cat that's
dog-like and wants to
love you worship you and not reject you
then you feel
you love the cat-back that's me i'm
shallow so
this cat is really sad this really cat
is
really going at my legs really begins to
have an affinity for me
i get down on my knees were you wearing
shorts or pants
i don't walk in pants you're wearing
like were you wearing that carpet suit
from way back in the day that we had
nope just
my straight carpety legs were the things
that they were this cat was rubbing on
and my wife got a picture with it not a
great picture it was dark
i was looking down but she posted it on
twitter and
uh i said more to come i actually i
think
i tweeted something like i uh
breaking news i have found a cat that i
think i like or something like that
i did see that so let me just tell you
that we began to
really i began to always want to walk
past this house
oh a tryst and this cat
seven out of ten times would be there
no no identifying marks i mean other
than it's what it looks like i mean no
no no okay no leash of course it wasn't
carrying a leash no collar and uh
it would just come out into the road and
i mean but it would always come from
that house
even though it didn't have a always come
from that house like he would be in that
front yard of that house sometimes it
would be sitting on the steps
and also people feed feral cats when we
walked with
barbara it would come up to barbara like
hello friend
on four legs yes like and barbara you
know how barbara reacted to that cat in
the video
barrow just kind of was indifferent
towards this cat but did not growl did
not hiss didn't do anything
it didn't bark neutral territory not
your home that's what people are saying
in the comments
and um i began to really like this cat
and i actually began to think things
like
i'mma steal this cat well i thought that
a little bit i wasn't gonna admit that
uh no one would know i started to think
i think i could have a cat boy wouldn't
that wouldn't that send waves to the
internet
i mean maybe i think a little too highly
of myself but um at least through the
fandom it would send a ripple through a
subset of our fandom right
and uh so and then one time
the last time most recent time i saw the
cat
jesse and i are walking he comes up he
does this thing
i pet him he's purring he's meowing and
then we start walking he's like
i'm going to walk with you guys just
starts walking with us
walks a full block and at that point i'm
like
do you really want to keep walking with
us i mean this is a four mile walk bud
and he seemed to understand the english
and he sort of slowed down and turned
around but i started to think this is
you know
uh we live uh you know there there's
coyotes around
you know and i've seen uh in in our old
house
coyote get a cat i once found or a
little dog i told i think i told this
story on a
air biscuit in times gone by found a
half a cat just a half a cat in my front
yard one time
yeah right so that's what coyotes do to
cats they take half
hey you were halfway there way back then
you just didn't know it they take half
they leave it
yeah i love her and um so i was worried
about
cats but i love them in their whole form
especially any
it was just the back half of the cat
which the coyote is the interesting part
so i i i was i was worried about this
cat i was like you just can't
be befriending everyone look at you with
emotions you can't
just go up to dogs and people like you
can't just
trust people i felt like i had like a
fatherly instinct to be like let me
you need to watch videos about strangers
and vans and stuff
so carry a picture of a coyote next time
you walking past
just the other night oh no is this bad
jesse and i are walking
getting ready to get up to the house get
to the house
on the post in front of the house there
is a sign
what it is a picture of my friend and it
says
lost cat you stole the cat i did not
steal
the damn cat the cat's gone oh no
and uh both halves
i'm i'm assuming the cat's gone and then
i then on the rest of our wall
didn't have a collar i noticed i had a
collar
uh i noticed there's a sign for a cat
if you care enough to make a sign when
the cat's gone you should care enough to
give the cat a collar before it's gone
i just think this cat didn't need a
collar
but anyway there's other signs all
throughout the neighborhood
dang and i was just like what does this
mean what is the
you know i don't really believe that the
universe is telling me things but i do
find it
uh somewhat helpful to just assume
the universe is telling me things i find
that a useful way to live
if god i'm going to say god is going to
tell you something that's
interchangeable with the
universe for you then he's going to tell
you something
i hope it's going to be not about a cat
well i mean
what what are you if if it if the
universe is telling you something what
is it
why is this about you i'm just well
because i'm somebody lost their poor cat
i'm interacting
with this cat so okay in my world and my
point of reference
okay i need to understand that's a weird
question to ask
i'm just messing with you
um i'm trying to figure out
how i should interpret this sign you
know i was moving towards a cat
i was opening my heart towards a cat
i was enjoying time with cat
and and now cat is gone cat was taken
from you and listen
i listen i feel for these people uh
but that cat is dead i mean i i
interacted with that cat long enough to
know that cat
in our neighborhood that cat is not
around anymore you thought but
i mean maybe somebody didn't say for a
second you thought about i'd like
i wouldn't like a cat i would like this
cat and i will and one time barbara did
the one time barbara got out of our
house you know the story she
she literally like somebody stopped and
saw her walking down the street they
opened the door and she jumped in the
car with them that is the kind of
dog that barbara is and that's the kind
of cat that this cat was
it's like it's a it's a lover it's not a
fighter and so it tried to love a coyote
and i think the coyote gave it a special
kind of love back
again the collar thing reduces the level
of sympathy but i do know
that there are people who will feed
uh feral cats and they will consider
they will have a relationship with them
but they won't let them in the house
this is clearly that kind of
relationship and yeah we had a guy who
was moving out of our neighborhood who
was uh
friends with christy through the gym she
used to go to and he was like listen i
know you guys live
near me a couple of streets down the
hill
this is an odd request but we're moving
um
do you want our cat would you would you
feed our cat yeah would you take care of
our cat because it's a
it's a feral cat it just it runs through
the neighborhood but we feed it and she
shows up every morning
and i want to bring her to your house
and have you feed her and have her start
showing up at your door
like he was really concerned about this
cat and i guess
no you know you can't have it both ways
it i would think it would be weird if
that cat
a feral cat who you just happen to feed
and have a relationship with
when it goes missing you would put up
signs to then what
start bring it back it will come back
but it but it goes all it's a free cat
that cat hold on the short life that
lives i'm not a cat ex
was a full life man i'm not a cat expert
but i i tend to believe
that feral cats in the in the in the
traditional sense are not as
people you know if they don't come up to
people
meow and yeah that's true and rub on
them this is a this is a house cat
this is a this is a cat that has it both
ways this is a cat that gets whatever it
wants
this cat definitely was on the inside
and the outside and you know what
this is like this is like a cat in a
halfway house you know what i think we
can celebrate the cat's life
and we don't have to feel sad because
that cat had it all
half he's in half right now that cat
everyone it met
it just it just showered with love i
mean no offense to you i don't think you
i don't think you were special no no it
just ended up it ended up developing a
special bond with you you were a
giant dude walking a dog if it came up
to you that cat would come up to
anything you're right
it would come up to a coyote well i
don't my dog does the same thing my dog
has no loyalty to me and
i still love it um my dog would have
gone home and just
started a new life with that other
family i know it for a fact so you never
thought about it
okay well maybe that cat did you name it
it has a name
and it's on the sign but i didn't want
to say it because i don't want to
you know i don't like people making
connections it had a name but it didn't
have a collar with the neighborhood
that kind of still doesn't add up i
don't think i'm missing anything emma
it's just i think it's pretty simple
you're gonna post signs
when it's gone you need to give it a
caller before it leaves
yeah i think the cat is just was a loose
they were holding onto this cat very
loosely and they lost grip but for you
the cat was an angel
leading you to the love of the female i
didn't know where the relationship was
going but it was going places very fast
and i was just letting my heart
just take flight i i wasn't it ended all
too soon
i i was rerouting my path to this house
i was spending quality time with the cat
i was getting pictures with the cat
um are you okay i don't i don't want to
cross over i don't think i'm okay
uh because i don't think i'll find
another cat like this you won't i know
for a fact
i mean first of all if you don't like
kittens
you don't have a heart you're not human
if you don't like kittens like no one's
like couldn't suck
right kittens are awesome i gotta have a
kitten
um but the chances that the kitten turns
into a regular cat pretty high
so high so high and at that point it's
like i'm
i'm not interested anymore i i do i i
i want the animal to love me i i'm
getting emotional support from this
animal
i mean when i do my stretches in the
morning and barbara gets on me
i need that i become dependent upon that
you know what i'm saying if when barbara
leaves or barbara dies
she will be replaced potentially with a
clone of her
or probably just another dog
um a lot of responses to our prompt of
what question keeps you up at night
we're related to dogs uh they were
really a lot of people are kept up at
night thinking what does their dog think
of them
uh no one thinks about what their cat
thinks of them because i think they know
right um we already talked about that on
a near biscuit
so for all of you who did we not devote
an entire ear biscuit to this to what
your dog is thinking
yes i i think that was what we call
somebody recently rabbit whole episode
you guys so look back look back through
that if you really wanted us to discuss
that because we're not hitting on that
today
somebody recently said because it is
happening so regularly now that we've
got so many episodes of your biscuits
and so many episodes of good mythical
morning and good mythical more
that we will have a conversation about
something the bidet conversation
and we're like blown away yeah we talked
about the bidets last week or week
before whatever
you were like guys you did a whole
episode on gmm where you
highlighted this product you really do
forget
an episode as soon as it's done don't
you and the the fact is
there's just so many yeah yes i forgot i
saw that
i saw it i mean i knew that they existed
but i didn't you know
they didn't exist in my accessible world
well the interesting thing about that
um because the the memory did flow back
when i saw that
the little segments from the show we
were wearing fake butts and we were
testing
strange butt products and one of them
was a portable bidet
and it was different than the one that i
got it did you look at it is it
no i didn't watch it oh you didn't see
the picture why is it in the bathroom in
there i got it here well it's like a
teal color and it's got a longer wand on
it
and the wand doesn't fold down oh my
wand folds okay i'm pretty sure the wand
doesn't fold
how does the wine not fold what is that
what happens then it's just
don't squeeze it until you're ready i
think okay uh so here we were squeezing
this thing on each other's fake
butts over our pants which had our real
butts underneath
and we were just talking about how i
mean the scent i don't i didn't watch it
it was a gif
so it wasn't anything to listen to but
we were just talking about how
strange it was and oh how we have
changed
oh yeah we love it now as we said get on
the train
we did it and we don't even remember
when we thought it was
weird that's how revolutionary
this is two episodes ago because i yeah
yeah well because the other thing people
pointed out that's how that's how much
you
that's how much it can impact your
rectum our conversation
about uh tau
um yeah and some that was another one
and somebody was like guys
and that link was invited the context
context
on good mythical morning a few weeks ago
we did the thing where we tried a bunch
of different
uh levels of chinese food super
expensive to super expensive and the
super expensive
restaurant that we got the food from was
called tau and i talked about how i went
to my friend's birthday party there
super fancy whatever talk and link was
like
why didn't i go and i said why didn't i
go and at the time i didn't remember so
i figured that you were invited but i
thought it would be funny to act as if
you weren't invited
so we had that conversation people were
like
it's funny how often people get try to
read so many things into the things that
we say to each other
i love it though that's why i feed into
it but um
they were like link is really upset
about not getting involved i was so
upset
yeah i was so upset you weren't he was
invited to tao
he couldn't go for some reason the irony
but
the irony it was 2017. yeah oh that was
a long time so many years ago the irony
of my joke
is that i know it elicits a lit it
elicits that response but the joke is
predicated
on some people's assumption that
whenever one of us does anything
that the other person should always be
invited
like that we're we're always there well
it's like when people find us in public
and they say where's link
i'm like i don't know find us in public
find yeah or
either one of us right they ask where
the other guy is it's like i could be
anywhere in the world
and the 90 of the time if i'm by myself
where's link i don't know i don't
track him you know what i'm saying
i mean he i but we are together a lot
and every time they see us
we're together so they just assume that
must be the way that they exist
we are together a lot yeah but i've
never been to tao
and you we we totally forgot that we had
that conversation
which at that time you were you were
like you were invited
and i was like yeah christy was invited
but then she forgot to tell me and then
she forgot about it and we made other
plans but do you know
think about how think about how
impossible it it would be to have a
brain
that could access all your memories but
also at the same time
access the venue at which you access
those memories publicly
you know what i'm saying it's like yeah
so we've had so many conversations on
your biscuits on good mythical morning
et cetera but we've also had a lot of
conversations
just in life amongst friends with just
the two of us here
and they're part of the brain that would
be able to catalog
every single memory and also attach a
little
flag to it that says that conversation
happened on ear biscuits
nobody except a very advanced
yet to be invented artificial
intelligence could be able to do that
but we have it we have a brain extension
and it
is the the mythical beast right the
phantom
that remembers these things because
you know of of all of them out there
that are that are talking on the
mythical society that are talking on
reddit
for sure in is it they're accessing
and you know binge watching and just
having this
it's very fresh to them and they can
remember it because if they hear us talk
about something and they've heard us
talk about it before
it's easy to remember that i've heard
that story about the chinese restaurant
before
because they don't have to know exactly
where it took place even though
this person who found it did know
exactly and then cut it out but i do
think that
and it's it's changed how we talk about
things because
we've come to grips with this reality
slowly over time
i don't know exactly how you feel about
it uh but i know that i am overly
sensitive to it
even like i made a comment after our
last ear biscuit i was like you know i'm
not happy with
i don't like referring to stories that
we've already told
or retelling stories like and you know
and
you're like hey people like that because
it gives them a sense of
if you're referring to something that
they missed it's like hey i should have
been listening earlier i should have
been
i should have been a part of this and
everything every new thing we talk about
is something that then can be a
reference point later because it's part
of our lives and
even if we forget it you can help us
with it but and if they remember it then
they feel like they're
a part of something they've been they've
been around so i think the thing that
the way that this phenomenon has
impacted us at least one way
is we kind of
own the fact that
we do things for comedic effect that you
know and
it seems it doesn't denigrate our
sincerity
but it's it's just strange dance that
for for the longest time you know we
would we told the stories we put it out
there and then you tell the stories
later and they're a little bit different
or they morph or whatever and we talk
about like how memory changes and like
we give ourselves the excuse but
basically
there's also this like you said about
the cat thing
years ago we wouldn't talk about the cat
thing in that way and i i think
that's part of the phenomenon of like
the constant communication with our
listeners is that
they know us better than we know
ourselves sometimes
and so hey it's like oh we just said
that for comedic effect or
you know what we forgot that so i filled
in the gap with something a little bit
different
or whatever the case may be or there was
an example of the uh
i don't know if it was i think it was
the wired auto complete
interview that we did and um
all the comments are we basically it was
one we were in one of those weird moods
where
it's early in the morning in new york
city and we did that interview yeah
and we usually take a super like
sarcastic tone
when it comes to any of that sort of
those interviews
that are done in that way because we're
like we're just here to be funny right
and we almost get
so committed to sarcasm that we make a
mockery of the whole thing
and so people who watch that the
comments are
i don't think any they told any truth in
this
interview i think that they were joking
the whole time and then if you don't
know us
the tone switch between being sarcastic
and being truthful
especially for me there is none there is
no tone switch
[Laughter]
it's exactly the same you just have to
you have to be on your toes
but there's a little there's a twinkle
in the eye yeah you gotta really know it
yeah yeah but usually it's the context
of what i'm saying
is how you know whether or not it's true
and then sometimes i watch something
back and be like
yeah that's i seem serious there but i
wasn't i get it if you thought i was
serious there
i don't blame you so i don't know when
we're now
we're just turning it this turning in
this into like a self-analysis podcast
we do that too much
let's just announce let's analyze other
people's brains
and what keeps you up at night but first
uh we don't have them with us and this
is one of the disadvantages to recording
here at our secondary location but
we got a new product we're always doing
things that are just we're trying to do
things to mix things up
we got something called the color
changing myth of cups we got
it's a four pack of plastic cups that
when you put cold
beverages into them or just liquids i
mean you could put poisonous liquids
into them just don't drink it
it will change color
i mean we have we sell the only cups on
the planet that do this
it's a proprietary science that we have
uh we've monopolized now see that was an
example of sarcasm
uh i'm sure there's other cups that do
it but they probably look stupid and
they're not related to us
yeah so buy hours that was truthful
mythical.com
there's other things besides cups as
well we're sipping your boys we're
actually thinking about selling like a
cup for a baseball player as well
that changes color when it gets hit with
a ball it's like did i just get hit with
a ball
yep or it changes color when you put
your balls in it
are my balls in this thing yep there it
is it's red
okay let's be ready well because it
could be any color you want
uh let's start with a question from look
at this why don't a cup
yep you know how you got truck nuts
have a fake pair of nuts what yeah like
have a
have a have a sports cup
shaped like big nuts
like you're whispering to yourself i'm
thinking out loud what
i wanna i wanna i wanna wear a cup next
time
i play baseball yep that the actual
shape of the cup
is two it's got two
uh two places for bulbs two bulbs it's a
double
bulb well in order to have a double bulb
you've got to have a ridge in the middle
and now you got a ridge in the middle of
your scrotum
which is not something anybody wants not
everybody's nuts hang the same way not
all everybody's nuts are the same size
why are we talking about this because i
think there's a there's white space
in the in the
in the cup in the in the cup world cup
world the cup vertical
i think i think we can uh definitely we
can wedge into the cup world yeah
and rhett and link cups available at
mythical.com
it's where uh the cup
is shaped like nuts and maybe we got
some that are just
one nut because some people got one nut
some people got three nuts
well they need to get together
it's like an average job some sort of
foreign exchange situation
okay first question uh is from caleb w
francis we're big fans of caleb he uh
funny funny funny guy i found him on
tick tock
and uh now we you know we follow each
other on social medias
of different sorts he's got a question
he went to the beach i've been following
his instagram stories he
i think he took like a full
cross-country trip apparently oh i saw
him on a beach
at the beach at one point he got to a
beach
um why do we only get two sets of teeth
the first set only lasts like five to
six years and the second set is supposed
to last a
possible 90 plus years seems like we
could use more sets of backup teeth
oh now caleb thank you for uh
responding you know you're a you're a
public
comedian you know it you gotta there's
this moment
when it's like okay am i gonna respond
to somebody some other creator's prompt
it's like okay if if he considers
himself
just a fan and he's responding that way
then as a mythical beast
boy that makes me feel good caleb i'm
glad you're in the fold
and if you did it just because for other
reasons i'm glad you did anyway you know
what i'm saying is
if you still want to use this teeth bit
as a funny tick tock you should still do
it
right you know in fact it may even be
cool for people who connect it to
yeah see if you can do that now this is
a great question yeah
two things come to mind for me the first
thing we you know you've heard this you
know that
elephants have a certain set of teeth
number of sets of teeth and then when
the final set wears out they die that's
how they know they're supposed to die
my teeth are gone and that's not
actually how it works they just can't
eat anymore
but the second thing that makes me that
i think about is
i often think about when people get
their teeth knocked out
in sports hockey whatever just maybe an
accident with a weed whacker
it happens right yeah and the only thing
i'm thinking about when somebody gets
their teeth knocked out as an adult i'm
like that's it
those teeth are gone forever like now
that you're gonna have some kind of
denture situation
now it's one thing if you get dentures
when you get old um
but when you're like 22 and you get your
flight your front teeth knocked out
it's like damn you got to get dentures
now right i mean i guess they maybe they
got some sort of technology
good they're pretty good at that though
yeah i think people
i don't think it ends up being that big
of a deal i mean but think about the old
days
think let's go back before modern
dentistry wooden teeth
wooden teeth man even before that let's
go back to people's teeth let's go back
to people's mouths like the cave people
think about how devastating
it would be like you get into a fight
and you're like i'm going to punch this
i'm going to punch you in the face
it's going to break your front teeth and
so for the rest of your life on this
earth
you can't like bite a turkey leg well if
you're not
not if you normally knock a couple out
you can still bite out you can't bite it
in the same way you can be a side biter
and you've got a little mouth like me
side biting is difficult
so i don't want i think you should have
backup teeth i mean i don't know how
many teeth caleb has lost i mean i'm
you know it's like what and i don't
seems like he might have lost some adult
teeth
i don't think they're wearing down like
i mean i see a lot of old people and
yeah yeah it's not about it's not about
wear and tear
for humans as much as it's just about
it would be not it would be nice to what
if it happened like a shark
like they i mean they just they're
lining up like in a coliseum to drop
down
you know i am not with you on this one
caleb because
if there's anything i hated in childhood
it was getting my toenails cut
but if it was anything else it was
losing teeth
man losing teeth was like pulling teeth
for me
it's horrible like i never
my aunt vicki man i went over to her
house and like
i would let the tooth just rot out and
it would just it would have to fall out
on its own
thanks but but she would get antsy and
she would say come over here i'm gonna
wrap it up in a kleenex and yank it out
this is where being an only child gave
you a disadvantage in this area when you
have a when you have siblings yeah they
do things like
tie your tooth up to like a
three-wheeler
and you know what i'm saying like what
happened to you no but
that's an exaggerated form of the kind
of things that happened you did cold do
something to you
i don't have any specific memories i
have more like
i've watched this happen on the internet
type memories and i'm sure that we did
something like that did you enjoy
pulling your own teeth uh i enjoyed
right after
it was pulled because it's annoying for
it to be loose
yeah it's like having this weird thing
in your mouth and you're like i gotta
get rid of this thing it's like a jostly
hangy rock there's a sense of euphoria
when it comes out and then it never
after it comes out it's like oh that
didn't hurt
you know what i'm saying it's like but
that it's it the it's bloody and it's
fleshy under there and the color of that
pulpy flesh is just
gross don't look at it it's in your you
have to really make an effort
and then then a few hours later you got
to eat something
this is why i still have my wisdom teeth
by the way
you know what i should have had those
pulled decades ago well you don't need
to worry about it now and now it's like
well as long as you keep them clean
so i i try really hard but i don't
i mean if if i had to look if i was like
oh you know
middle age about to get my about to get
my old man teeth
they're they're wider and so for every
two you lose you get one in its place or
something interesting like that it's
i don't know it'd be something to look
forward to but the losing thing
even even at this age like i
i've never pulled any of my children's
teeth
i can't believe that lando he would get
so annoyed with him
he would he would pull him out that's he
worked up a lot more courage than me
normal childhood
behavior but lando is a lot like me at
that age
there was there was a lot of
just nervousness
right so i'm aren't you a little
surprised that he's just yeah yeah
yeah so i'm i'm proud of the guy
just because he's got brothers and
sisters even just the presence of
of siblings has an impact on that kind
of thing
i that's my theory but i don't think
you're talking about
pulling teeth i'm talking fairy the
tooth fairy would sometimes wait
over a week to come and get that tooth
from him
the tooth fairy doesn't visit our house
we i don't know if he knows where we
live
um i think this is more
this situation that i'm getting at which
is you accidentally lose a tooth for
some reason right i
certainly hope this doesn't happen to me
in my adult life but it could
wow you really fear this i would say i
have a
irrational fear of of getting my teeth
knocked out
first of all just whatever happens does
it break off or does the root come out
too it depends on the nature of it man
i mean i'm thankful that we live in
modern times and it will be a relatively
easy
thing and i've got plenty of friends who
were like oh yeah this whole half of my
top
teeth are fake or something like that
and you know i had no idea
but but it's interesting because
you know evolution has doesn't have an
awareness of any modern technology right
so evolution is just happening blind
blindly based on
people's environments and adaptations
and so for whatever reason
it it was not seen as advantageous
to have another set of teeth but you
have to know
that lots of people are losing teeth and
now in the modern world with sugar
basically just sugar you got tooth decay
that
also evolution was never prepared for
right so you've got like certain
cultures that are like living in the
amazon and all of a sudden they're
introduced to modern foods
and then their just teeth start falling
out because they have not coupled eating
sugary foods with modern dental hygiene
you got to have both of those together
and even sometimes if you do if you
don't do a good job at
cleaning those wisdom teeth they're
gonna have to pull them out someday
so i don't know i don't really
understand why we don't have
the backup teeth but it was just
determined to not be
worth the genetic effort i'm so thankful
for that
the thing about wisdom teeth is you pull
those out and they don't want to come
out
that's the that's what's been so scary
for me all these years
yeah my father-in-law pulled mine
because he's a dentist and um
and he just has a wanton desire to yank
something that he loves it's perfectly
at home where it is out well he loves
oral surgery in general
and in my mind he like had one leg
up on the dentist chair like you know
what i'm saying like it was like one of
them was so
my roots were twisted and like he was
like my head was like
like you know like really like he was
like i was having to like hold my neck
back and it's like makes
it makes a popping sound when it comes
out i don't recall the only way i would
do it
is if i was drugged so aggressively
okay this this next question this is a
head scratcher
i think i do have an answer though that
or at least something that can guide us
this is from uh
is that ziley's servant yeah sid
um if a blood donor kills someone
can the person who received the
murderer's blood be convicted of the
murder based on dna evidence
this is why blood donor donating is
anonymous so you can't frame somebody
does this happen it doesn't matter if
it's anonymous because
let's just say you just received a bunch
of blood
and then you got mad at somebody or
there was just some
justifiable reason that you wanted to
kill somebody and you did it and in the
process you were like stabbed
and you bled in the crime scene could
the dna of the blood let's just say you
got like a almost a full blood point to
the donor
yeah uh so we're not a scientist i think
that's been
made abundantly clear but we do know how
to read articles on the internet
well but i didn't read any articles so
go ahead and give me your best guess and
i'll give you
some some scientific guidance afterwards
i think that you're
you're let's see because dna i mean
there's certainly dna in blood
because it's just a cell they all have
the dna
but to me it has to do if you did it
immediately
like you got a you got a like a huge
freaking blood transfusion like
the i would say it would have to be like
90 over 90 of your blood would have to
be replaced because
i i think somehow you get so you got to
have
maybe i was i'll say 65 of your blood
has to be replaced
and then very beginning very specific
you have to murder somebody within i
would say an hour
boy that's tough to get a blood
transfusion and then murder somebody yes
you're pretty weak at that point
that would be so badass but you walk
right out of the hospital and just kill
the first person you see or just do it
right in the hospital kill the person
who is giving who's saving your life
there's irony yeah but that we're not
going to really need much of
much of an investigation if you kill
like the person in the hospital bed next
to you
that's true giving you below okay okay
okay i'm glad i'm not a criminal
you know what i'm glad you're not a
detective
but i i think that your blood um
assimilates very quickly like foreign
blood
is it is accepted and like the dna
is replaced or there's just not enough
of it there's
and it i think that's what it is so
it has to be quick and it has to be a
big transfusion
i mean i think you're basically right
thank goodness scientific american has
this article from
2009 by michelle gong michelle
n gong an assistant professor at the
mount sinai school of medicine explains
so we got an assistant professor
well i mean that doesn't i mean she's
probably a professor this sounds like a
ta to me
um so basically i'm not going to read
this
article but it seems to be the case that
there's not
there is dna in blood and blood that has
been transfused
but it is almost certainly going to be
overwhelmed by the dna of the recipient
like so
in the in the crime scene uh now you're
kind of talking about like
just blood everywhere typically dna
evidence is like
hair skin cells
saliva there's more than just blood
right
but even within the blood and i guess i
mean if you
if you replace 90 of your blood
i don't know what the case is but
typically if you just go and you get you
you receive blood because
you needed a blood transfusion that did
like a certain percentage of your blood
it says that donor dna and blood
transfusions uh
in the recipients persist for a number
of days sometimes longer
but his presence is unlikely to alter
genetic tests significantly
basically you once you go and you start
it happen though
like analyzing the dna the overwhelming
dna
signature will be from your existing dna
right
um but if literally if that one
situation
where you just basically are full of
donor blood and
it's got the dna now it says something
about like transfused blood
um red blood cells the primary component
and transfusions have no nucleus and no
dna
what transfused blood does however host
a significant amount of dna containing
white blood cells or
leukocytes around a billion cells per
unit roughly one pint of blood
red blood cells have no nucleus and no
dna
so yeah so you not saying that there is
not a dna signature there but
there's gonna be red blood cells you're
gonna have some red blood cells uh are
you gonna there's gonna be
uh d there's gonna be some dna there and
then yeah your body quickly assimilates
i don't know what that process is like
and how your
the you know the dna gets overwhelmed
and replaced but
i think that the chances of that
particular situation of somebody
getting all their blood killing somebody
and the majority of their dna being left
at the scene is just more blood
it's probably never that we've probably
never had the opportunity to experiment
with that
specific scenario i'm sure there's been
somebody
who's who've they've taken like a pint
of blood
that's not theirs with them to frame
somebody
but you gotta you forensically you gotta
be real smart about it but i think you
should i think actually
taking i've noticed enough csi i think
you take
hair spit and some
skin if you really want to leave
the mark from somebody else but getting
getting all that from a person it's
difficult you want to be you want to you
want to receive a blood donation
a hair donation and a skin and spit
donation
well and then kill somebody if you
coordinate this right you could do it
right first of all you got to develop a
relationship with her barber
right yeah um you can get lots of hair
from a barber
and you can come up with all kinds of
semi-legitimate reasons why you would
need it
i'm going to make a making a sweater for
my kid
i do you know that the most comfortable
pillows are made of human hair you don't
want to tell the barber something that
seems like a great business idea
it needs to be something personal not
something scalable like hair pillows
yeah i want to do a one-of-a-kind hair
painting
for for for that guy
who was just in your chair who i'm
actually framing for murder you know i
want to give him a hair
hair painting gift i believe that this
is one of the scenarios where you're
saying
exactly the truth like sometimes in
movies like the killer
will say exactly the truth and it's so
outlandish that it just
nobody takes it seriously i want to
frame this guy for a murder i'm about to
commit
right i just give you the hair and you
walk out yeah so that's easy get the
hair
skin uh you gotta talk to their i guess
masseuse
[Music]
you gotta talk to their masseuse you
gotta be like after you rub this person
down
can i can i slow down for science
purposes can i
yeah get can i get a sample skin this
from your hands
uh spit that's super easy
and there's a number of ways to get
people spit
you could be like a fake 23andme kind of
service
get them to spit in something uh you
could be
you could probably go door-to-door we're
collecting the neighborhood spit
yeah you could you could people will
probably give you their spit you could
um just click
just clean there i think the best thing
to do
clean their house like show up as a
cleaner oh this is first service free
you get every you get all the cells you
want of every type
and you can also dust for fingerprints
and then maybe create some sort of
freaking tony danza
okay that was it uh okay um what's the
next one the next one is also a crime
question oh yeah here we are
csi don't get fooled again
mariah uh
i don't see mariah's handle because i
screen shot this
incorrectly mariah though
if someone is framed for we're in crime
framing
if someone is framed for a crime and
ends up in prison but then they
escape and while they are on the run the
police figure out who really did the
crime and put them away instead but the
person who wasn't supposed to be locked
up in the first place have to go back
for escaping prison or would they just
be free
since they technically weren't supposed
to be there anyway
well so if you're if you're wrongfully
convicted and imprisoned you escape
and then at the same time exonerate
exonerated
enter harrison ford um
i'm not lying and this was not a setup
for this question
but me and shepard watched the fugitive
together
like three weeks ago i remember that
being a good movie i watched it
basically when it came out one of the
like 94ish 92
early 90s one of the things that i end
up doing quite often when i'm trying to
figure out what we're going to watch as
a family
i saw a movie oh yeah yeah link has seen
this movie which is
pretty phenomenal yeah okay there you go
that's all i needed um
i'll look up like top 100 thrillers of
all time
you know i was like i want to watch an
action movie a good action movie with
shepard
and uh pulled out the fugitive and of
course
as it's coming on first of all there's
this there's a moment in every
movie that's made before like 2004
where kids know because
the credits are so long at the beginning
of the movie they're like what is this
opening title sequence for like three
minutes where they're telling me
everybody who did everything in the
movie like
you can't do that anymore because people
like what the hell is this
put that at the end i don't care about
it a lot of movies they put the title at
the end now
yeah you got no time you got to get into
it man i'm not a fan of that by the way
title at the end not a fan of the title
at the end i want the title up front
but i don't need i i watch the credits
i'm you know i'm in la
i'm in the industry i stick around and i
watch the credits until the movie's done
when i go to a theater long opening
sequence to the fugitive
but uh this is the plot of the fugitive
which is a
by the way highly recommended movie and
yes we are going to spoil it but you can
imagine
if the setup of the thing is the guy is
wrongfully convicted for a murder
in this case the murder of his wife you
can imagine that he's going to exonerate
himself but the movie is basically about
him being
a fugitive he's being chased by a
federal agent played by
tommy lee jones oh yeah at his finest
oh yeah well at his tommy lee jones i
mean he's just
the same guy in every movie and
he's on the run and then he's trying to
prove his innocence and he has an
outlander story about a guy with a
prosthetic limb who killed his wife
turns out that it's got some stuff to do
with some pharmaceutical scheme etc
but and also jane lynch makes a cameo
before she was you know a household name
she's like she works at the hospital
anyway
in the movie and i based all my legal
opinions off of things that happened in
movies from the night he never went to
prison
he didn't escape from prison did he oh
yeah he was
i thought he escaped he was in custody
on the way or something
well he was in custody whether he's in
prison or not he's in custody
he's on the inmate bus yes and
presumably he's already been
in uh you know he's been in captain he's
been in jail
awaiting trial he gets convicted he's
being transferred to prison with a bunch
of prisoners
in a bus the bus wrecks
and he's given the opportunity to escape
and he takes it and then he's on the run
and then he spends the whole movie
trying to prove himself innocent
and of course spoiler alert he was not
he's totally guilty no so and at the end
of the movie
when uh basically you know tommy lee
jones you can kind of tell
is becoming convinced of his innocence
as the movie is going on
and so at the end of the movie it's kind
of like dude i know you like escaped
the deal and we've been running all over
the place
but you can't do it yeah you know you're
you're innocent so yeah go
go free tommy lee jones did let him go
yeah he's i don't remember that yeah i
mean he's
the implication i can't even though it's
only been three weeks i can't remember
exactly what happens
the implication is he's exonerated
himself everybody knows it and he's not
going to be in prison
and he's not going to be this is the
thing because in america
i i went to uh quora which is like where
people who
are sometimes experts or at least claim
to be experts or think their expert
answer questions and the answer to this
question was filled with a bunch of
people saying that at least in the
united states
uh the act of escaping confinement
is in itself a crime and often
involves some sort of property damage
and maybe some sort of assault
is required in order to get out so but
let's just say that it's a perfect
situation you didn't break any laws
you just like you looked and all of a
sudden like the gated prison was open
and you just walked out yeah you
technically committed a crime when you
did that
but in the court of public opinion if
you're exonerated when you're out
the judge may say okay the time served
yeah time service right
uh in some countries especially if the
time you've served is more than the time
that would have been for a
prison escape you know what i'm saying
yeah
in some countries i have read it is not
illegal to
escape in prison i saw that too uh but
can that be true
but there's you it's it seems true
because i read it
and it was like it's grammatically
correct how was that possible
uh but you typically like saying you
should escape and then i don't know the
one thing i read was like
you know because it's it's it's the
natural you can't punish somebody for
their natural
inclination to want to not be imprisoned
but it's a real world what would they
have a natural
information kill somebody that's a
ridiculous rationale but even in those
countries
there's typically other infractions
associated with it that you can still be
con
convicted for and put back behind bars
associated with an escape
and then there was this one anecdote of
this guy i think in germany where
it is claimed to not be illegal to
escape
that um the
his prison outfit showed up at the
prison
laundered and folded in in uh
considered con in his considerate way
shipped back to them
so then they didn't have you know he
didn't steal the
oh it sounds like an urban legend yeah i
have but i read that i
have my doubts about the why that would
not be the law but i don't know i don't
i never thought about it
um you know you talk about exoneration
in movies like i do i i think about the
hurricane
denzel washington i definitely want to
see that again
uh it's been a long time since i saw
that
that was a good movie um it's a really
good movie i gotta gotta watch that one
again oh you know another good movie
that's along the same lines uh just
mercy i uh
watched that recently new movie michael
b jordan
but again based on a true story uh like
a young
attorney uh trying to to to prove a guy
innocent
and uh the guy still to this day
operates this institution that is
basically like the innocence project
kind of thing but offering legal
yeah i was going to mention the
innocence project because once you start
thinking about
the just the the horrifying reality of
being
falsely imprisoned i mean there's one
guy who
was in prison for 37 years and then
exonerated
you know for a rape he didn't commit i
haven't
i have an incredible story i wasn't
planning on telling but it's this
is my dad told me this i was talking i
was talking to my dad
uh who up until this year he retired he
was a
law professor and of course he was a
lawyer before he was a law professor
and um i was talking to him about how
much i enjoyed just mercy which is the
story again of a young attorney
a young black attorney going down to
alabama
and trying to prove like sort of
re-examine the evidence around
this uh black guy who was falsely
accused of murdering a white woman
and uh it takes place in like that just
mercy takes place in like the 80s or 90s
90s or early 90s i think
um and as you can imagine the guy was
wrongfully convicted
uh i was telling my dad about it and
he's if you're going to make a movie
about it then yeah right
he starts telling me a story i'm like
why have you never told me this story
before
so when my dad was a
very new attorney like had just
graduated from
from law school and like just got just
past the bar
he's a you know at that point you're
kind of assigned cases
and uh so
there's a there's a guy um in
who's who is a security guard
in uh at the smithsonian in washington
dc
okay and like whatever year this is you
know my dad's beginning to practice
law so early 70s and
he uh a guy breaks into the smithsonian
and he has to shoot him and kill him
wow and as they're kind of now
he's innocent for shooting the dude but
in the process of like examining like
who this guy is they're like
this guy is a prison escapee the
security
a security guard this guy escaped from
an
alabama no i guess it was georgia
from a georgia chain gang in like 1940
so like 30 years ago right
and he was convicted of
some crime i don't know what it was i i
don't know what the crime was but
he was he was convicted of a serious
crime a felony and then he was on the
chain gang and he escaped from the chain
gang
and then goes on to live a normal life
but they find
oh this guy is freaking uh
from a chain gang and so they assigned
the case to my dad
to defend him oh wow and uh my dad sits
down with him and basically he's like
this guy
uh went on to live a completely
fruitful you know life contributing to a
society
and also by the way because he my dad
asked him flat out he was like did you
do the thing that you were convicted of
he's like no
and he was like he he he said i i didn't
even have the opportunity to enter a
plea
and so my dad's like okay yeah georgia
1940. i can imagine that this is the
this is the k
the way it was so my dad starts looking
at the like
the documents like the records and
he finds that there is a guy who some
position in the court
uh who was overseeing like an attorney
who was overseeing these cases
at the time who is still alive and who
is now like
90 years old and lives somewhere in
georgia
and my dad goes to the dude's house
which is crazy because this is
kind of what happens in just mercy but
like you go to these people who have
something to do with the case of course
in just mercy it's just you know
you know a decade ago or whatever but
this is like decades ago
and he sits down with this guy and he
says this is my client and this is what
happened do you remember this case and
he was like
i don't remember the details of that
case but i'll tell you the way that it
used to work
he said every monday morning everybody
that we had arrested he said every black
person that we had arrested
okay uh we'd bring him into court and we
would enter a guilty plea for all of
them
everyone he says would not give them an
opportunity to testify
would not give them an opportunity to
even to enter a plea they would
represent them all as a
as a collective regardless of what had
happened whatever they've been arrested
for
just enter a guilty plea and then
sentence them
systemic racism it's real so there's no
trial it's just a conviction it's just
yeah yeah yeah yeah
he's so he's like well we obviously this
is wrong
and so um my dad like takes this i
i don't know exactly what he did but he
basically takes this evidence to this
thing and they
and the judge says all right uh this was
a wrongful conviction and he's he's free
but then it it's appealed
or they have to take it to the to like
the district court
which was in new orleans and my dad is
you know who's he's green
he's green he's already received like
his like 500 bucks or whatever you get
to to represent somebody and you're not
supposed to receive any more
he's like uh do you want me to go to new
orleans and defend this guy
and and the judge was like yep and we'll
make sure that you you know
we pay for your your expenses or
whatever you didn't have any money
so he goes down there and basically
presents the case to
just a big court like a district court
is just a bunch of judges like
overseeing a bunch of cases
right um and they let the dude go
dang that that needs to be a movie man
yeah i was like dude i was like dad this
is basically just mercy
well i was like why have you never told
me this story the interesting thing
about it
is that the guy you know it's
i mean after decades maybe there's not
as much fear but there's still got to be
this thing that's like
i could i haven't been caught but i
could have
i could have been found out and it could
still happen
and i'm a security guard and i'm doing
everything right
but then he's presented with this
opportunity i mean
to do his job requires shooting somebody
in the smithsonian
or not by the way he didn't you know
at that moment he it sounds like he did
the right thing
where that put him in in danger of scr
the scrutiny
that then it came to pass you know so
doing the right thing
put him in the crosshairs of going back
to prison yeah
well i think the thing that just mercy
uh highlights is that
okay yes you know because of the civil
rights movement things have gotten
better
that ex that exact scenario doesn't
happen anymore
but the fact is is that the roots of
that systemic racism
are still very alive and well and we and
they continue to be cut back they
continue to be
uh rooted out literally and
but you know as recently as
you know the early 90s it was all
basically
almost exactly the same scenario but
just with one individual guy
and then this stuff is still you know
there's still a lot of this existing in
sentencing
and um you know
it's it still exists it's like if you
any sort of
nonpartisan evaluation of the current
justice system shows that there is still
um a bunch of inconsistencies in a bunch
of injustice
towards people of color you should still
around
and that's why blm exists yeah
but by the way you should get some more
stories from your
from your dad you should uh well he's
got a really good one i i think i've
told before about the uh
being attacked by some uh
some female inmates who uh escaped from
a place that he was like working
he got he got like they teamed up on him
and beat him up and got out
what like two or three female prisoners
yeah it's uh
he's got a good story about that too
were they innocent did he exonerate them
after the fact he represented them
[Laughter]
okay if we got to we could do a we could
do a crime podcast
we kind of did like a whole different a
new podcast
just turn this into a crime podcast
crime biscuits
well hopefully you'll sleep a little
better at night some of you
uh yeah and we you know what there's
many more questions that we didn't get
to so we'll do this again this was a fun
conversation
led to some really interesting places uh
you know what i wasn't going to make
this my wreck but i am going to make it
now that i talked about it just mercy
the movie
uh just i mean it's super well done
first of all
uh you got jamie foxx playing
uh the guy who was convicted you got
michael b jordan playing the attorney
um really great performances and i just
think it's one of those things that i
think it's important to
um you know especially if you
question whether or not this the
systemic racism that people talk about
actually exist and based on some of the
stuff that i see on the internet a large
percentage of people at least in america
continue to question whether or not this
is even a reality they think this is
just some trumped-up [ __ ]
um that's trying to support some kind of
marxist movement or whatever the latest
conspiracy theory is about it um
when the reality is is there's a lot of
injustice that's been
been done and this movie does a great
job it's just a great movie it's a great
story
and it does a really good job of
highlighting exactly
how frustrating
it would be uh to be a black person
in the justice system especially at that
at that juncture in that place
in the deep deep south alabama um
so just mercy watch it it's good and if
you want to go back
a few decades the hurricane is a
is a similar story yeah all right
hashtag air biscuits
let's continue the conversation let us
know what you think
and we'll speak at you again next week
because
that's what we do we want to we enjoy it
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right
to watch the previous episode of your
biscuits click on the playlist to the
left and don't forget to click on the
circular icon to subscribe if you prefer
to listen to this podcast it's available
on all your favorite podcast platforms
thanks for being your mythical best